Tamaz Gadaev: О соре?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да ничего Как, слышно видно, все, Хорошо?
Tamaz Gadaev: Багда?
O!Sapiens Expert: А супер?
O!Sapiens Expert: Так, Готов, начать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Супер. Тогда передвинешься. Дальше. Как Обычно, по практике предлагаю. С?
O!Sapiens Expert: Заземление. По этому устройству. Подобне?
Tamaz Gadaev: Давай?
O!Sapiens Expert: Слабься закрой глаза и мы сделаем. Три. Серии. Вдоха и выдыха, и, Глубоки вдох, до полноты легких?
O!Sapiens Expert: Второй, догоняющий?
O!Sapiens Expert: Не план. Медленно. Вдыха?
O!Sapiens Expert: Замечаем ощущение в теле замечаем, эмоции, мысли даем, вам Просто быть никак не пытаясь ничего изменить или поправить просто наблюдаем?
O!Sapiens Expert: Второй, глубокий?
O!Sapiens Expert: Догоняющий. Щит?
O!Sapiens Expert: Плавно Глухае. Внимание на то, что, есть какие, то, дела какие, то, мысли, за пределами ты встречи и они могут, сказываться. Но, пока. Мы. Их откладываем, в сторону чтобы сконцентрироваться на, этой работе?
O!Sapiens Expert: Быть здесь. Сейчас. Идем Третий, изгвышающий?
O!Sapiens Expert: Полное удвиха возвращаемся в ощущение в теле, на ощущению, гравитации ощущения одежды, воздуха, температуры, потока и всего?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что возвращает наше внимание к этого моменту. Здесь, и сейчас.
O!Sapiens Expert: Когда готов нужно открыть глаза. Мимо. Чтобы?
O!Sapiens Expert: Добро пожаловать. Так, меня. Вопрос. Мы с твой не виделись в Пару недель как ну перед, тим как, мы копнем дальше. Как у тебя? Сейчас Вот в этом моменте. Здесь. Уровень Энергии и состояния?
Tamaz Gadaev: Прямо сейчас! Я бы сказал, восемь, девять из десяти у. Нас сегодня абсолютно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Крейзи День приезжает три новых человеков в команду. Всем нужно. Делать. Интро со всеми знакомиться я вообще на.
Tamaz Gadaev: Напике?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сейчас!
O!Sapiens Expert: Круто, окей, тогда, Давай, Кратко, Пробежимся, по, этому периоду который мы, с, тобой не виделись бы недели мне, не надо Счаствуйте подробное чего, то. Просто как, то верхней уровнего были ли какие. То интересные, наблюдения?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ааа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Общем?
Tamaz Gadaev: Первое, что, если, нормально, спать, у меня, пропадает ценливость?
Tamaz Gadaev: Если удивительно, да.
O!Sapiens Expert: Вау, Супер?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но Если спать там от семи часов хотя, бы то, сонливость меньшее врядностью наступает это. Хорошо?
O!Sapiens Expert: Сейчас! Зазвини Маленькое точнение это. Вот этот дип в, ранее. Пяти вечера или это в, целом.
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, да, да, да. Да дифред пяти вечера?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот.
Tamaz Gadaev: Это первое?
Tamaz Gadaev: У меня не получилось трекать еду она, эта быстрая штука отпала она слишком?
Tamaz Gadaev: Короче?
Tamaz Gadaev: Слишком требует много. Ресурсов. Нужен. Телефон всегда, чтобы, нужен, не забывать про это и так далее?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот.
Tamaz Gadaev: У меня, стал, я стал естественным образом раньше ложиться?
Tamaz Gadaev: У меня По. Прежнему бывают периоды, когда я там типа, в два ночи двум тридцати ложусь, но, это, особенно когда, там?
Tamaz Gadaev: Поработать. Хочется?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но сейчас, уже к часу, как бы раньше у меня вообще в, час ничего даже, не играло о том что можно ложиться спать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сейчас. Уже я когу. Постепенно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Приближаюсь к тому Я прихожу в комнату. Там уже постепенно. Короче, Ложусь?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот спать я. Стал лучшем. В. Среднем?
Tamaz Gadaev: И еще я стал?
Tamaz Gadaev: Больше, уставать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Это, связано части с тем как, я сейчас в себе день организовал, что, мне типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Все встречи. Там, Типа До четырех где, То до пяти?
Tamaz Gadaev: И мне, после этого нужно еще много депорка делать Какого то, фокуса?
Tamaz Gadaev: И учутвая что меня, сперва съедают много социальной энергии встречи.
Tamaz Gadaev: Потом я чуть отдыхаю и, у меня потом долгий дип Фокус Я. Стал Быстрее засыпать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот и я стал использовать, йога нидру?
Tamaz Gadaev: Для засыпания. И мне это стало помогать тоже что я обычно перед сном прошу его недру. Включить?
Tamaz Gadaev: И типа расслабляющиеся. Такое?
Tamaz Gadaev: Виза, Спа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот со сном стало получше?
Tamaz Gadaev: У меня что мне не получилось. Не получается раньше вставать. По прежнему?
Tamaz Gadaev: То есть?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. Я. Допустим, если, я просыпаюсь пораньше мне, все еще хочется лежать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Типа. Я не выталкаю себе в душ.
Tamaz Gadaev: У меня. Ну.
Tamaz Gadaev: Нет, давай. Так?
Tamaz Gadaev: На какой то процент я стал раньше просыпаться и Мне. Стало, хватать времени на дыхание. Раньше. Мне вообще Не Хватало времени. На дыхания. Сейчас! Уже?
Tamaz Gadaev: В семидесяти процентных случаях, Мне хватает время на дыхание пятнадцать минут грубо говоря но, все равно?
Tamaz Gadaev: В целом. Последнее время я режу чувствую, ну. Очастя, пенно, что, стало лучше спать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Реже стал чувствовать этот дип по энергии?
Tamaz Gadaev: И еще заметил, что, если во время этого дипа поэнергия?
Tamaz Gadaev: Есть какая то встреча, где мне нут есть какой то, Фактор внешний который, требует от меня собранности?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я не замечаю этой дип энергии То есть. Что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. Дополнительная. Мобилизация, группа горя. Мне Нужен там. Выступить перед людьми например у меня, организм Включается, и я ну, не делаю?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, не происходи по?
Tamaz Gadaev: Еще Одна Вещь которая стала, делать это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Микроспорт?
Tamaz Gadaev: Допустим там попрыгать на скакалке, поджиматься, что. Такое сделать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Бо, одну, Пару раз ходил в качалку но качал качаству это очень, нерегулярные занятие.
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот.
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот такой набор вещей?
Tamaz Gadaev: Еще, что, не получилось? Это? Ну Вот это, вот. Строгость. Соблюдения. Типа вечернего ритуала когда?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, я точно в такое то время поднялся. Точно в такое то время у меня там приглушается свет?
Tamaz Gadaev: У. Меня, пока этих отсечек нет, то есть У меня. Пока просто общее ощущение, Когда нужно ложиться спать оно подвинулась Пораньше?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но вот вот этот алгоритм который, мы тогда задали он ломается о. Части потому что вчера нужно было встретить человека?
Tamaz Gadaev: Из другого города?
Tamaz Gadaev: Там типа. Это была ночью?
Tamaz Gadaev: Позавчера. Мне нужно. Было очень важно было доделать одну задачку по работе?
Tamaz Gadaev: Типа. Да, и там, когда то, бывает там, с кем, то?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну, Какой, то разговор происходит классны С Сотрудникам? Которые, ты, не хочешь пропускать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот.
O!Sapiens Expert: Я понял. Спасибо. Интересные наблюдения?
Tamaz Gadaev: Атак?
O!Sapiens Expert: Еще копнем тут. Относительно тех ночей когда, у тебя получалось придержаться системы или, может, быть с, того подхода который, мы наметили. А что тебе помогало в те Не Знаю вечера ночи, ни, с тем, чтобы?
O!Sapiens Expert: Следовател?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Блин, самая помогающая вещи это. Когда, Я устаю?
Tamaz Gadaev: Типа, когда я реально хочу спать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот Обычно я укладываюсь спать не, хотя, спать я такой, пора спать Ложусь Йога Нидро все и постепенно меня струбает?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но когда я прям чувствую сонливость этого замечательно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот тут. Помогло. Ну. Короче, уставать. Помогает.
Tamaz Gadaev: В это вкладывается. Спорт?
Tamaz Gadaev: В это вкладывается?
Tamaz Gadaev: Когда у меня более структурированный рабочий день когда, я точно выжимаю из себя все, социальное, а потом, выжимаю, из себя все. Фокусное.
Tamaz Gadaev: Тогда вот мне, прямо ну. Меня, меня. Рубят.
Tamaz Gadaev: Это больше всего?
Tamaz Gadaev: Второе?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я стал лучше засыпать себе гонидрой да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Третья больше. Такое психологическое что типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. Два Тридцать для, меня. Теперь это. Красная зона типа если олег, в Два Тридцать это значит хуе?
Tamaz Gadaev: Раньше, Было так. Что, типа, ну, ладно, два? Тридцать? Типа, нормально. Успел.
Tamaz Gadaev: И я стараюсь, как то, вот появилось. Это.
Tamaz Gadaev: Это давление. Что, типу, нужно все успеть побыстрее типа ну, не, в Два, тридцать лечь?
Tamaz Gadaev: А пораньше?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот.
Tamaz Gadaev: Что еще, что еще помогало?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну помогла когда, вечерних, никаких, активностей нет понятное дело?
Tamaz Gadaev: Когда ничего вечером нету я там, не гуляю ни внизу со с. Командой нигде короче просто когда я, дома лежу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что, ты делаю?
Tamaz Gadaev: Естественно ну, переключиться, в сон довольно быстро особенно если если, я, хочу спать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Кей?
O!Sapiens Expert: В. Те Ночи вечера когда, не получалось что, было первое что сыпалось?
Tamaz Gadaev: Когда не получалось?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну, Вот, у, меня недавно был случай когда, я работал до самого позна?
Tamaz Gadaev: Мне не хотелось дач отпускать, типа. Вот я хотел это делать.
Tamaz Gadaev: Наверное, могу и отпустить?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но вот, оно, как то, шло, шло, шло. Я хотел. До логической точки завершить.
Tamaz Gadaev: Как то?
Tamaz Gadaev: И при этом мне было бодро достаточно кости. Я бы мог и дальше работать, но я себя отсек, типа, нет. Когда что после?
Tamaz Gadaev: После двух. Уже лучше не работать.
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, это.
Tamaz Gadaev: Еще бывает?
Tamaz Gadaev: Переживание, но с ними мне, кажется. Что, я, уже, понимаю как справляться, В смысле когда ты лежишь?
Tamaz Gadaev: Был какой, то яркий день, Например?
Tamaz Gadaev: И прямо, я чувствую как напрягается голова я, Начинаю Мыслить какие то, вопросы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот там, йога. Не допомогает Вот. Я, вчера себе поймал несколько. Раз Типа йога не. Дройдет.
Tamaz Gadaev: Я понял, что я, начинаю пропускать инструкции, и у меня на голова напряжна о. Чем ты. Думаете какую так расслабляем голову тебе экспресит ли?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот требует много осознанностей, чтобы это делать, Но как бы это можно делать?
Tamaz Gadaev: А ну Естественно дисраптев всякие, штуки, когда. Вечерняя. Активность какая нибудь, когда не знаю свидание, или, или, какая то, тусовка, или что, то такое?
Tamaz Gadaev: Там у меня. Нет даже убежденности, что мне нужно это пропускать с мысли что, я такой я. Сейчас жертвую сном?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что бы, вот мне сейчас, было класно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Там, или или полезно, или что то еще такое?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ничего, ты. Поупоминал. Это был. Тебя день когда ты там два часа заранее поспал. Как тебя с этим, было?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да кстатью Вот это хорошая штука, когда я совсем не высыпаюсь после десравти в. Дней?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я делаю сон?
Tamaz Gadaev: В днем, типа двухчасовой, кумерной?
Tamaz Gadaev: И это мне помогает зарекаверить?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вечер, то. Есть если, я вообще не сплю?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я поспал три часа почему. То? Тусовка, была например?
Tamaz Gadaev: И если в следующий день я, вообще не сплю?
Tamaz Gadaev: Кто этот день пройдет в никуда?
Tamaz Gadaev: Если я себе?
Tamaz Gadaev: Запланируй. Что там? Типа? В два часа. Я Легу Спать и до, четырех буду спать?
Tamaz Gadaev: В четыре я. Просыпаюсь там душ поесть раздупляюсь, покурить?
Tamaz Gadaev: К пяти Я уже готов что, то делать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот из половину дня. Я все могу засеять. Таким образом?
O!Sapiens Expert: А потом, в этот, день, как с засыпанием, нормально?
Tamaz Gadaev: Нормально. Дашь? Ну? Все, одно я, мало спал?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы прошлый раз говорили про то что, есть как будто какое, то, внутреннее не знаю внутренние, назвем этоттак между тем что вроде, как хочется или, скорее, нужно наверно, нужно больше из развяда спать но, при, этом оно как, будто, бы забирает время от работы?
O!Sapiens Expert: Я тебе хочу спросить Вот. Те дни ночи с кариной роки Ты Высыпался вот следующий день с. Точки зрения продуктивности каким он был для тебя?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. Было, очень приятно что, нет туди по энергии?
Tamaz Gadaev: Зависит меня. Сейчас. Дни довольно хаотичные типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Скаже. Так. Мне. Больше от негативного запомнилось?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Когда у меня происходит, типа, провал поэнергии?
Tamaz Gadaev: И я понимаю, что следующие два, там три часа, мне будет, тяжело. Работать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я чувствую?
Tamaz Gadaev: Облом, что типа Блин, я бы мог, типа, на час дольше. Поспать.
Tamaz Gadaev: Я бы сейчас я чувствую нормально, и типа, мне бы это ничего не сбивало?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот это чувство. У меня?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как бы запомнилось, и оно регулярно возникает когда от этой сонливости, есть?
Tamaz Gadaev: Теперь такой доеобы на в Рот, Но почему сонливость Но теплой? Мне не нужно быть сонливом. Сейчас?
Tamaz Gadaev: Когда я, продуктивна, это, как бы то дефолт смысли это, есть, Я это. Ожидаю от себя всегда?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот такой момент?
Tamaz Gadaev: Откуда сопротивление? Оно, в целом Как бы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Короче, очень неприятно сознавать конечность количества часов. В сутках?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот что, когда, например, отче то происходит, если я там смерсажусь за фокус работу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Неф пять, скажемо, а, там в восемь я. Такой но, были на еще в семье всего там. Типа, четыре, пять, часов?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сейчас, Тем более, я там еще пойду там, отдохнутусь. По факту. Три, Три С половиной может быть.
Tamaz Gadaev: Очень жаль, Типа. Я хотел вообще сделать. Сегодня. Многоче.
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот и в целом психологическая штука. На самом деле, очень такая. Может быть ключевая?
Tamaz Gadaev: Может, быть это из института, привычка, или что? Но есть ощущения?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что ночь, Время бесконечно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Если у меня есть ночь?
Tamaz Gadaev: Кто я могу сделать? Все что хочу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот я там, к экзаменам. Готовился. За ночь?
Tamaz Gadaev: То есть, какие то важные презентации я делал за Ночь?
Tamaz Gadaev: То есть, как бы я такое, ну ладно сейчас. День, Заканчивается через допустим десять одиннадцать вечера ночь, что у меня, есть, То есть у меня, будет там контейнер времени, когда я точно все успею?
Tamaz Gadaev: И там не ощущается. Конечности. Количество часов?
Tamaz Gadaev: Отчасти потому, что, может быть, ну, что, там долгий блок. Работы. Есть, но типа, есть там пять часов блока, или, точно такого, если до четырех утра скажем?
Tamaz Gadaev: Когда, ну Когда Ничего, нибудь дергать, когда я могу, тебе спокойно погрузиться, и вот он ощущается? Как что, так что можно воще все за него успеть сделать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, А вот это понимание, что Блин, у меня сейчас в час. Нужно будет ложиться спать оно давит, чуть, чуть, поддавливает?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот у меня. Вот это приятное ощущение бесконечности времени, за которое я могу все успеть сделать, оно, у, меня ну. Как, Бы, постоянно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Оно не мешает, сколько то, это вот. Я. Мною. Не принято конечности. Количества часов в суттка?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей? Что, здесь самое сложное для принятия?
Tamaz Gadaev: Самое сложное для принятия?
Tamaz Gadaev: Наверно, вот что это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это Значит что, я сделаю меньше чем, хотел?
Tamaz Gadaev: То есть, я немит своей экспектейшенс. По части. Того, что я сегодня сделаю?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Обломна. Это ощущение облома?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что у меня, не будет победы, сегодня, какой я хотел.
Tamaz Gadaev: Сколько то тревоги, наверное, есть. Поэтому поэтому по этому поводу, что типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Нужно, двигаться быстро а, там нужно результат делать Там Есть план и всяко, такое?
Tamaz Gadaev: А я там?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну? У, Меня, экспектейшенс в. Этом плане выше чем, чем, я могу сейчас сделать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот и зафиксировать, Но это? Как зафиксировать прибыль? Я называю зафиксировать убыток верни, Это Если, Ты там?
Tamaz Gadaev: Открыл позицию там. Не знаю Ты там Вложился в, какую то, Акцию она начинает падать вниз и нужно в какой, то момент?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. Там, не вариант там дольше дольше, быть с акция. Может. Неседаток работает но типа, когда нужно, зафиксировать убыток типа все убыточный. День?
Tamaz Gadaev: Все Я дальше. Ну засейвется Скажем. Так.
Tamaz Gadaev: И вот, зафиксировать убыток по продуктивности. Это неприятно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы еще вернемся здесь. Еще небольшой уточняющий момент?
O!Sapiens Expert: Когда Ты Говоришь что не, будет победы под победой что ты для, себя подозреваешь?
O!Sapiens Expert: Афина, Что Ты Категоризируешь как победа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Результат, которым я доволен, то есть ощущение, того, что я сегодня хорошо поработал. Допустим, я там?
Tamaz Gadaev: Чем сделал запустил эксперименты, Они там поехали. Завтра будет. Результаты отих экспериментов. Классны?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот И вот это ощущение, что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Есть результат. Приятное?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как бы его не. Будет У меня скоребуют ощущения, что нет результата, который?
Tamaz Gadaev: Нот. Больная. На сколько то?
O!Sapiens Expert: Кей. Из условных?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ста дней где, У тебя есть определенное ожидание того что это, победа скольких, из. Них. Это была для. Тебя Фактическая победа.
Tamaz Gadaev: По ощущения. Поэтому да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Тут нужно поделить типа. Что, есть разные виды побед как, Бы Есть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Нов скидку?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я бы, сказал, процентов, наверное?
Tamaz Gadaev: Тридцать может, Быть подбор, реально. Была победа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Нож двадцать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей, Давай, это, пока, припаркуем.
O!Sapiens Expert: Не кажется есть, над, чем порефиксировать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: В рамках этого тезиса К минимум общего контекста, того как ну, собственно, строится, отношение, к. Восстановлению и подходу к, продуктивности Если это три из десяти то ну да, тут. Конечно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Здесь есть вопрос ожиданий. То есть, в связи с Эйч, Ди, мне?
O!Sapiens Expert: Самосовой?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как бы на вопрос продуктивности накладывается вопрос оценки?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как бы оценки, того что я могу сделать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ия?
Tamaz Gadaev: Искренне не понимаю. Иногда, насколько я хорошо типа, оцениваю штуки.
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, Это нормально. Это субъективный аспект, Но мы можем когда вернуться окей давай. Попробуем, Поговорить именно про то к чему, Мы сейчас пришли. У нас Считай месяц, уже прошел, и хочется понять что, для тебя было может быть самым значимым что?
O!Sapiens Expert: Получилось. Внедрите поменять за проше месяц. Где Ты видишь, какие? То заметные изменения?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Наверное, как бы, вот самое ключевое для. Меня это.
Tamaz Gadaev: Создание фокуса. Какого то, на том чтобы спать, нормально?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что от это появилось очущение, что мне не нужно, типа, бесконечная ночью. Сколько угодно делать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Регулярные воспоминания о последствиях?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот.
Tamaz Gadaev: Я думаю, что в какой то мере еще меня подтолкнуло?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это. Ну. В, среду себя получен, настроить?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Типа, там, телефон убрать, кровати сделать, там место где, я могу поваляться с телефоном вне кровати?
Tamaz Gadaev: Какие то еще штуки?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот.
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Это, вот чисто ощущенческое. Такое, что, вот?
Tamaz Gadaev: Чуть больше ощущение. Ответственности за то как, я поспал перед собой завтрашнего так скажем?
O!Sapiens Expert: Грейп, На уровне осещения что, то понялось?
Tamaz Gadaev: Самочувствие?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Да, сонливость, стала реже типа она, была каждый день практически?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сейчас. Сонливость?
Tamaz Gadaev: За последние две недели. Наверно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сорок процентов. Дней. Может быть, вот, так?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей Да, звучит. Как прогресс?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну И, плюс я, стала чаще выгонять мысли я стал?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я чувствую сонливости, я иду прыгать на скакалке, допустим, там да потом душ потом, полежать?
Tamaz Gadaev: И как то, это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Обратить на нее внимание что ли, не просто?
Tamaz Gadaev: Быть, Как то ну тащить, ее сквозь рабочий день?
Tamaz Gadaev: За Фэйситет, Йога?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, супер механизмы. Какие то, которые помогают всем справиться лично мы? С тобой ну внедряли. Определенные. Подходы. Протоколы не хочется понять, насколько сейчас с ними вообще обстоят дела с точки зрения того это, уже, на уровне привычки или это, Пока еще, из разряда каждый вечер. Надо как то себя заставлять и уговаривать, себя ну там условенном премьер?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы Говорили о том что такое, хард, стоп, в два часа как сейчас, это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Скорее заставлять, приходят сюда?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Tamaz Gadaev: То есть, это, но, по крайней мере?
Tamaz Gadaev: В смысле, раньше, Мне общения была созданности про то. Что, нужно хорцова Два Часа делать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сейчас ощущается поддавливание, что типа нужна два часа но, где нужно прикладывать усилия в том чтобы отцепиться, от текущей задачи например?
Tamaz Gadaev: Тайстиа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Выйти из текущего там. Режима Фокуса. Скажем. Так?
Tamaz Gadaev: Или выйти с текущего режима. Когда мне приятно внизу Там с людьми проводить, время?
Tamaz Gadaev: И подняться к себе спать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Там. Это нужно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что де помогает этотва цепица?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сложен. Сказать. Не, Могу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Наверно я могу предполагать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Наверно, мне поможет?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ли, бан?
Tamaz Gadaev: Зэ, Фэйсид?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как бы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Прочувствуй, Да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Тревогу. И Облом, которые ощущаю от того, что я, что то недоделаю?
Tamaz Gadaev: Иля, того, что я выйду?
Tamaz Gadaev: То есть, прямо такой, так, я еще собираюсь уходить там типа, перестала. Делать задачу.
Tamaz Gadaev: Типа. Ну. Да, больно, хуе, мне, Не Нравится, Вля, Сука не хочу. Это, Делать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот это сделать. Прям.
Tamaz Gadaev: И, наверно, будет проще это сделать. Я располагаю, так?
Tamaz Gadaev: Поистирить немножко внутри по поводу, того что не так получилось, как я хотел.
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: А. Я. Эти дни?
Tamaz Gadaev: Возможно, вспомнить о последствиях. Ну. Типа, как, бы я последствиях помню, оно. Всегда как, бы висит?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну, ну, Да, Что, как, бы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Какое то более положительное подкрепление, что тепло?
Tamaz Gadaev: За то, завтра я буду разебывать отмера. Отак Вот?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
O!Sapiens Expert: А есть Ли может быть какие, то наблюдения относить дово чем отличаются дни когда, получаются как, от царем справиться и напомнить себе и втоге сделать то, что, ну, запланировал нежели, вот. В, те дни когда, это не работает?
O!Sapiens Expert: Я хочу понять есть, ли, какие, то закономерности?
Tamaz Gadaev: Черри, подумаю?
Tamaz Gadaev: Наверное, понимание, что мне нужно. Не шесть часов сна, семь, хотя, бы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Типа или семь с половиной. Даже лучше?
Tamaz Gadaev: Мне помогает?
Tamaz Gadaev: Блин, хочется больше положительного подкрепления. На санделе.
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну, Как, есть пока, да.
Tamaz Gadaev: У меня полупень?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что помогает?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но на сам деле, Если работа была, какая, то сделана все таки то есть, если я для. Себя?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Тостью, допустим, мне, не сделал там?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сто очков. А сделал. Там, восемь стчков этак ну восемь сточков Нормально. Типа, пойдет.
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Когда какое то ощущение, что ли аккамплишмент?
Tamaz Gadaev: Имеется?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мир, повел?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, такой?
Tamaz Gadaev: Когда лос быть меньше?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тонкий, лед?
O!Sapiens Expert: Нужда, в. Этой системе достаточно сложно ну?
O!Sapiens Expert: Обеспечить себе прочный фундамент для того, чтобы каждый день следовать за определенным правилам если у. Тебя там тридцати из ста И Ну, в, тридцати процентов случаев ты доводишь до. Восьмидесяти условно баллов очков не важно чего?
O!Sapiens Expert: То это, каждый раз будет сопротивление. Что Ты Гублять что Ты, Не доделал и это будет каждый раз блоком здесь надо понять что, мы можем придумать для того чтобы, тебе помочь с этим потому, что это барьер который, ты, надо, перепрыгивать здесь возникает. Проблема. Но что, по, мере?
O!Sapiens Expert: Дня развития, событий, встречь, дел и так далее у. Тебя возможность принимать решение минимальное. Консульня А Это. Влажное решение которое надо принять здесь. У тебя, как это все, условно, говоря против, тебя сходится?
O!Sapiens Expert: Типа. Тебе надо принять сложное решение у Тебя уже ну не, у тебя, слова любого из нас уже нет ментально сил. Плюс, Еще, есть вышенное ожидание относительно, того чего я, сегодня там сделан сделал довольство, собой, аропардиона и работой и. Так, далее, и, это, все, оно, Так это начинает перевешивать в сторону того чтобы, оно сыпалось дальше?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот есть. У меня мысль одна?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я, какое то время делал такую штуку?
Tamaz Gadaev: Типа, работа со скукой типа. Мне там связи, создывакая, мне?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ненавижу делать скучные задачи и мне оточит тяжело я. Их. Постоянно прокрастинирую проебываюсь из, этого.
Tamaz Gadaev: И была идея, переформулировать типа работы со скучной задачей. Не так, что мне нужно сделать? Задаче, не мотивировать себя результатом.
Tamaz Gadaev: Грубо говоря этой, задачно что, мне походный результат, когда, я дела скучное.
Tamaz Gadaev: Аскорей?
Tamaz Gadaev: Превратить это в практику, то, есть, чебуду делать я буду. А мне, как, бы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Мышления практиками нравится. Сколько. Там. Разной Практике делают что типа? Я учусь, работать, со? Скукой я учусь, принимать, Скуку я вот как Такой типа монах?
Tamaz Gadaev: Который?
Tamaz Gadaev: Практика, которого, путь которого, это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Мочь, делать? Скучная?
Tamaz Gadaev: Не давать скуки меня. Типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как то, сбивать?
Tamaz Gadaev: И одна из таких одна из, таких практик это была?
Tamaz Gadaev: Все естики проругаться, выматыряться, в свои заметке?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сказать. Что, тебе рассука я Ненавижу эти задачи инахой вообще и, буду делать фуни. На фу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Поистерить, как, буда, от датите Мы эмоции.
Tamaz Gadaev: Пройти?
Tamaz Gadaev: И это, сколько то помогало?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот мне понравилась мысль которая возникла, сейчас что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что, как вот этот?
Tamaz Gadaev: Задача. Несмотря на то, что я, ощущают этот лос?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, это сопротивление и типа, облом?
Tamaz Gadaev: И тревога по поводу того, что что то не доделал?
Tamaz Gadaev: Задача. Не давать этот тревоги и лосу управлять Своим поведением?
Tamaz Gadaev: А как это делается тем, что я, могу, это чувствовать. Типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я могу это чувствовать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Короче, Нормальный конец. С этими эмоциями.
Tamaz Gadaev: И вместе с ними делают то что, правильно было бы сделать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Пойти, спать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Как кажется идти, поможет?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот.
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну можно попробовать как, минимум?
Tamaz Gadaev: В смысле, со скука Это помогло.
Tamaz Gadaev: То есть, каждый раз, когда, садился ругаться, в свою заметку?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я все одно потом делал скучно, То есть, это как?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но выработала в ста процентных случаев?
Tamaz Gadaev: Надо вспоминать ругаться в заметку как, Было?
O!Sapiens Expert: Кей?
Tamaz Gadaev: А здесь нужно вспоминать?
Tamaz Gadaev: О том чтобы, грустить чувствовать, облом и, не знаю раздражение?
Tamaz Gadaev: Не потом, вместе с этим раздражением, спокойно, типа. Ну. Окей. Да, Ты, все, можешь, быть я. Не сделал чехо. Я хотел Эпохове.
Tamaz Gadaev: Я буду делать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Потом глядишь, может, быть?
Tamaz Gadaev: Если я, буду лучше высыпаться там типа? Режим, наладиться. Я начну делать, что я себя. Запланировал больше?
O!Sapiens Expert: Я тебе говорю про предложение. Филл?
O!Sapiens Expert: Здесь, в кино молчать, зум, я. Могу потом в телеге продублировать.
O!Sapiens Expert: Это очень полезное приложение, которое помогает научиться выявлять конкретное чувство, которое мы испытываем. Но сейчас, не скачиваю потом. Скачаешь. Это Сейчас кратко расскажу сык теп продулиров телегу там. Есть очень такой понятный простый подход. К Тому собственно, как, вести дневник эмоции туда можно. Надиктовать. Там можно как раз, таки?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вылеть. Вот это всю не знаю фрустрацию, или, там не знаю не важно какие, чувства, ты, испытываешь, для того чтобы это помогло тебе, Каким то образом именно соелиться с этим, прожить, это, отпустить, это и не дать. Этому. Повлеть на Твое. Решение. Там можно настроить уведомление чтобы оно приходили пуш напоминания о том чтобы, это сделать там в определенный. Момент времени?
O!Sapiens Expert: Поэтому может, помочь Но перед тем, как переходить, к каким то решениям, давай еще прообежимся по тем ритуалам которым, пытались внедрить. И мне интересно, еще понять как у тебя сейчас проходит этот вайн даун. Период. Там. Тридцать. Минут?
O!Sapiens Expert: Как с ним?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что у тебя? В нем? Как Какие то элементы, которые уже получается делать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сейчас у меня вайн Даун В. Основном, Йога нидра находится то есть я, стал чаще но, не, всегда, но я стал оставлять комп внизу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что, что мне помогает?
Tamaz Gadaev: Мне нету нету, каких то вещей типа, там, растяжки, или, чего, то такого?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но я стал больше?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. Короче, Ну, по. Сути, медитировать геогенедре, ты, это делаешь. Меня очень помогает?
O!Sapiens Expert: Перед ней есть. Какой. То переход там за полчаса там, свет, или, еще что, то?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот. Я Прям престошаю?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, свет, и свет, обычно у меня не горить. Яркий свет, у меня горит там типа туск?
Tamaz Gadaev: Обычно я прихожу запускляю, свет могу полежать с телефоном. Еще. Какое то время?
Tamaz Gadaev: Че? То, кому то подвечать что, это поделать Такое? Уже?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но уже, не работаю. Там Не Знаю пятнадцать минут допустим.
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот и потом, я думаю, так все проспать.
Tamaz Gadaev: И ложусь надеваю. Маску. Включаю йога нитру?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага Окей А Освещение На. Мобилке настраивал На Красное?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, да?
O!Sapiens Expert: А как?
O!Sapiens Expert: Пощением?
Tamaz Gadaev: Нормально. Не мешает. Я думал, будет мешать. По целому.
Tamaz Gadaev: Салон? Хорошо. К, статьяна Компе. Почему. То не работает?
Tamaz Gadaev: Не до вчера, заметил?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, страна. Если это, мак, то там поединен. На автоматиче Оно. Можно настроить?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но Окей что сейчас скажется таким наиболее устойчивым из того что, нам, не дрели?
Tamaz Gadaev: Наиболее устойчивым?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что, кажется, наиболее, устойчивым?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я думаю, что привычки по среде?
Tamaz Gadaev: Телефон не попадает в кровать ноутбука, стоится, внизу это уже. Стало дефолтом относительно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Йога Нидра?
Tamaz Gadaev: Прямо Ну Она, устойчи, одно что, я кайфую без деца типа мне, нравится. Это Делать это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Относительно устойчиво?
Tamaz Gadaev: Стало, что дыхание стало больше утром?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, Ну, и еще Я, не знаю это не, практика, это скорее?
Tamaz Gadaev: Просто ощущение, тоже, которое я Ловлю что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Поддавливание со стороны ночи что. Типа, пора спать то есть? Раньше? И регнориировал, абсолютно?
Tamaz Gadaev: А сейчас, это. Ну.
Tamaz Gadaev: Каждый день. Плюс минус возникает?
Tamaz Gadaev: Если я начинаю там уходить в работу лишь это, еще, я аж, такой, блин я уже чувствую, что две, части борятся что как бы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Одна часть раньше вообще не. Боролись одна часть что.
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Я, не хочу фиксировать убыток да по. Работе. Я хочу там. Что то делать это, всяк, такое вторая, часть. Нет, Если ответственность перед тем, как ты завтра будешь там?
Tamaz Gadaev: К себя, чувствует про сонливость, воспоминания и так далее.
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Супер, Да, спасибо! Есть. Ли Какие то, у тебя инструменты идеи, как? Можем поддержать в этом вторую часть которая, за, то, чтобы спать И быть. Продуктивным Завтра?
Tamaz Gadaev: Есть?
Tamaz Gadaev: Блин у меня, почему, то это плохо работает?
Tamaz Gadaev: Кгбу. Дня. Есть логичный ответ?
Tamaz Gadaev: Типа. Если я хорошо поспал?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я себя, чувствую заебись?
Tamaz Gadaev: Нужно это записать?
Tamaz Gadaev: И ну записать что, тебе?
Tamaz Gadaev: У меня сегодня было там семь восемь, часов сна. Я не чувствую сонливости, и чувствую бодрость Мне так класно, Типа Блиатомас Спи, Пожалуйста, побольше?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот из. Когда я в это попадаю, я могу это записывать.
O!Sapiens Expert: Плохо работает почему.
Tamaz Gadaev: Но?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, почем ты не знаю может быть. Я мало, это делал может Нужно, Попробовать?
O!Sapiens Expert: От это делал?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну, Сколько, Ты, Делал, да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну, ты, Меня, записал, или это, просто как мысль?
Tamaz Gadaev: Мне описал в этой табличке. Было много всего записано.
Tamaz Gadaev: И это правда мало. Потом перечитывал?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но это было записано тут, скорее?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сейчас я еще подумаю?
Tamaz Gadaev: Часть, которая, мне скорее кажется?
Tamaz Gadaev: Скорей хочется подойти из стороны ослабевания той Части который, меня хочет держать в фокусе?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тоже можно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот Ну, тут, да, тут. Типа, прочувствувате эмоции вот. Эти?
Tamaz Gadaev: И позже себя успокоить я думаю. Что Типа ничего, все, нормально типа я не, проебался. Бы я и так. Сделал достаточно вещей?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я там?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, Ну. По, сути его, такой можно так их сделать что типа.
Tamaz Gadaev: Тем, что я сейчас ложусь спать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я увеличиваю продуктивность на завтрашний день. В смысле, что то, что я сейчас, не успел сделать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Если завтра буду выспавшимся, Я там типа. За час?
Tamaz Gadaev: За крою?
Tamaz Gadaev: Плюс закрой еще шесть. Часов работы в более высокой энергии чем Если я, сейчас. Этот час отними от сна?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Какой аргумент можно привезти?
O!Sapiens Expert: Отлично. Ты. Упомянул что, тебе уже помогает как, раз таки работа. С окружающей средой и В Этом контексте можем ли. Мы найти, какой то способ, который тебе создался какой, то дополнительный якорь, в окружающийся где чтобы, служить, свой, роднопоминанием, для этой мысли потому что если это оставить, как мысль?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Есть опасение, что оно не будет во время?
O!Sapiens Expert: Напомнено?
Tamaz Gadaev: Смысле. Штука которая позволяет Мех вспоминать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вспомнил?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. Давай так.
O!Sapiens Expert: Какой то сигнал, физический. Объект?
Tamaz Gadaev: Доктор?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я все скажу на. Трансфори?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, есть, Например, такая, как бы практика?
Tamaz Gadaev: Которое делается после двенадцати?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это что сделать, это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Зафиксировать убыток.
Tamaz Gadaev: По сути, если он есть?
Tamaz Gadaev: То есть, дать себя, почувствовать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Неприязнь, Какую то тревогу?
Tamaz Gadaev: По работе если, она есть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Пожаловаться самому себе?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это одно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Успокоить. Себя что, типа все, нормально на. Сам деле это. Не так страшно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Гм?
Tamaz Gadaev: По этом, что ты не подолал все. Заебись?
Tamaz Gadaev: Успокоить, себя по части убытка?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: И третья. Это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вспомнить, что это вклад. В завтрашний день.
Tamaz Gadaev: Может быть сделать простую оценку?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Типа. Сколько у меня завтра времени уйдет на то, чтобы сейчас это делать?
Tamaz Gadaev: На смысле, завтра это, делать?
Tamaz Gadaev: И?
Tamaz Gadaev: Может, быть, когда я это сделаю, подумать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Может быть?
Tamaz Gadaev: Думать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что, но я себе, дам больше энергии и, все что, кроме, вот, этой доделки я завтра, Буду делать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Пижи на пятнадцать процентов запусти?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
O!Sapiens Expert: Отличный, Подход Мне Нравится к?
Tamaz Gadaev: Привет, это практика и, нужно вспоминать эту практику делать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вот как?
O!Sapiens Expert: Сейчас! Простой простой премьер. Если давай?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как я вспомнил?
Tamaz Gadaev: А есть у вас?
Tamaz Gadaev: Хорошая идея?
Tamaz Gadaev: А у меня есть Вуп?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вуп Умеет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вибрировать Вуп. Это хороший символ?
O!Sapiens Expert: Так?
Tamaz Gadaev: Символ здорового сна?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, Ты, его регулярно носишь в. Итоге все, же?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я всегда его ношу. Да, Ну, я, его зарядил все. Теперь. Я. Его нашу?
O!Sapiens Expert: А?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Последний этам?
Tamaz Gadaev: Последние две недели на шию?
O!Sapiens Expert: Гей, что ты можешь с ним сделать вибрацию?
Tamaz Gadaev: Просто поставить сигнал на Вуп?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Tamaz Gadaev: Типа, Что Он мне там когда, звонил, мертв пол перу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Супер?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Давай начнем. С этого защит, Как что то, реализуемое?
Tamaz Gadaev: Окей?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сейчас я подумающе раз?
Tamaz Gadaev: Дось. Мы Говорим что, корень, проблемы типа в моем эмоциональном отношении к отходу ко сну?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что негативные эмоции?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сейчас. Давай еще про негативные эмоции, тусти, игры Что Зафиксировать убыток бывает? Другое?
Tamaz Gadaev: Какие еще бывают эмоции, которые не дают мне спать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Незавершенность?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот еще плать второй класс эмоции.
Tamaz Gadaev: Когда?
Tamaz Gadaev: Когда я, остаюсь типа самим собой?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как будто бы день не дожит скажем так. То, Есть, Я тоже поработал я уже. Много. Всего сделал?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я был все время подключен, Каким то внешним вещам. А. От. Час например, я, хочу не знаю там?
Tamaz Gadaev: Пообщаться или полистать. Дейтинг?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Или?
Tamaz Gadaev: Какой короче, как нибудь побрейнротить просто самим собой побыть?
O!Sapiens Expert: К.
Tamaz Gadaev: И прямо сейчас! Лечь! Спать! Звучит?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как то, как будто бы я обрываю что, то, то, есть?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я, как будто бы не дал время себе не, знаю, я не Дал время потупить как то, себя почувствовать или, что, такое. Сделать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Даже хочу сделать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Какой то кайф минимальный, хочется?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот вот вот такое?
Tamaz Gadaev: Какой, то, какой то расслаблик?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это именно перед сном, или в течение дня?
Tamaz Gadaev: Перед сном Имена?
O!Sapiens Expert: Кей?
O!Sapiens Expert: Давай найдем что то, что тебе, это, даст?
Tamaz Gadaev: Какую, то, какую топнимальную расслабленность, что то, что мне, не держит меня В фокусе, что, Ты, что может?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Погибланить, как нибудь?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
O!Sapiens Expert: Сколько тебе. Времени надо на то, чтобы поиблань?
Tamaz Gadaev: Зависит?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну. На, вскидку?
Tamaz Gadaev: Блин. У меня был случаешь, когда я по Ябланил одиннадцать часов просто не уснул и, меня случайно попались рилсы. Я. Забыл что я не удалил. Он. Стул?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я ее оставил и удаляю всегда потому, что?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Tamaz Gadaev: Наличие. Инстын На Моем телефоне создает вероятность что, я не буду там долго спать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Поэтому я не держу у себя твиттер И инсту на телефоне вообще.
Tamaz Gadaev: А тут я, что то, поставила, чтоб счет запастить Забыл удалить, мне попал сырилось, и все. Я Я пошел В анканши По абсолютное в состоянии?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ох?
Tamaz Gadaev: То, есть можно сказать, что, одиннадцать часов да. Но, это крайний случай?
Tamaz Gadaev: Наверно, если это что то?
Tamaz Gadaev: Такое типа хелси Да? Давай, так это назвем?
O!Sapiens Expert: Га?
Tamaz Gadaev: Растяжка там. Медитация. Не Знаю?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну, ты, Это, Будешь, Воспринимать, как что, то, для себя, или нет?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но я люблю растягиваться?
Tamaz Gadaev: Медитировать. Я люблю?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но?
Tamaz Gadaev: Мне. Нету привычки. Кростяжке?
Tamaz Gadaev: У меня есть. Привычка к медитации, Типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Всегда, когда у меня есть время?
Tamaz Gadaev: Какое то я люблю, То есть, для меня это вообще не чер как, Бы не рутин в зал помер ходить мне сложно нужно заставлять.
Tamaz Gadaev: Медицирувать тебя, заставлять. Мне нужно.
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот. То есть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Смотреть?
Tamaz Gadaev: Если это сылся, короче, это меньше времени, Я думаю?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тут. Вопрос, Да, на сколько это соотносится с тем, что ты назвал брейнрот?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я думаю, что это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я не знаю есть, ли, потребности в брейнроте?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ипи поебланить?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вода. Тут. Поэтому надо понять?
Tamaz Gadaev: Понять какая, потребность?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
O!Sapiens Expert: Из разряда. Время для себя Концептуальная это понятная категория. Другое, Дело оно. Ну. Может. Быть, совершенно по разному реализовано?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну, Сейчас, у, меня какое есть ощущение что, нужно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Типа. Основная. Потребность в расслаблении мозга?
O!Sapiens Expert: Именно расслабление мозга, или этого для себя социальное, просто расслабление мозга. Это звучит лично для. Меня и, поправьте как, переключения как раз такие между там, словно рабочим, режимом, и тем, что, типа, уже, все расслабиться и можно идти спать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Расслабление мозга. Это скорее, чтобы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это отсутствие комитмента?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что это такое? Это?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Tamaz Gadaev: Отсутствие необходимости. Что то, делать. Это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угда Я от тебя ничего не ожидаю?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, Что это. Такое?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот с растяжкой и медитацией. В чем может быть трабл с медитацией полегшие? С, растяжкой что? Это такой?
Tamaz Gadaev: Нублять, вот. Я. Решил. Типа, как, зожник типа порасслабляться, вот я. Сейчас. Я заставляю. Там?
O!Sapiens Expert: Эшмар?
Tamaz Gadaev: Растягиваться тип типа того?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей Окей, Давай, Хорошо?
Tamaz Gadaev: А если они, хочу, А я хочу там не знаю полизать, тиндра или что нибудь такое, сделать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, не офлайн, были стояти давай. Найдем именно какой, то перечень, которой, будет для тебя рабочим но При этом Здесь важно Создать Рамку Ну что здесь также. Можно. Просто провалиться туда на количество?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ревиде?
Tamaz Gadaev: Че обычно. Сейчас, делаю тебе я. Могу полистать бейтинг.
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я уже перестал это делать, но это но такая практика у. Меня есть я. Могу поиграть в компьютерную игрушку?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
O!Sapiens Expert: Есть, еще тоже. Вопрос активности. Концептуально. Да, это все одно не должно быть, что то, что будет стимулировать нервную систему особенно перед, сном?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тонкий, момент?
Tamaz Gadaev: Когда бы, я читал, но это тоже зожный способ, типа ослобляться разложенные, не, в. Смысле не, то что, вы это, оскорбление?
O!Sapiens Expert: Я Прям этот что. Что, там лежит?
Tamaz Gadaev: В смысле?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это говорит та часть, которая хочет?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вообще ни во, что не комитится смысле которые не, хочешь чтобы одне что, то требовали?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Tamaz Gadaev: О Чтение. Это, Что, то что, требуют усилия, какие, то?
Tamaz Gadaev: И это как бы правильный способ Там. Типа. Вайн Даун Делать, то, есть у. Меня нет у привычки к чтения У смысле, я не тот человек, который в свободное время читает книги?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, я иногда тот человек, который в свободное время может?
Tamaz Gadaev: Порастягиваться. И Я точно тот человек, который в свободное время медитирует, то есть, разные?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Для меня вещее то, есть может, быть?
Tamaz Gadaev: Мой, способ, то что я там, я там медицирую, Кто то воспримет, как зожный. Да, я там книжку воспримия Как Зоженный способ?
O!Sapiens Expert: Слушай, Ну, Медитация?
Tamaz Gadaev: Поиграть в комп. Было прикольно практикой?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да играть в ком я. Бы Тебе не советовал тебе вообще не будет способствовать качество. Медитации на. Сам деле хуема?
Tamaz Gadaev: На сам деле?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Те, как с этим?
Tamaz Gadaev: Нормально. Просто.
Tamaz Gadaev: Охуенно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это у, тебя и нервная система успокаивает это вроде. Для. Тебя?
Tamaz Gadaev: Чуть, Чуть, больше развлечения хочется наверно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, да вот вот тут у меня. И были подозрения, что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Может быть?
Tamaz Gadaev: Может, быть какое то?
Tamaz Gadaev: Какой нибудь взять?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. Курс Не, Курс, что нибудь что мне, показывают разные, практне что, я медитирую плюс, минус одинаково. Всегда?
Tamaz Gadaev: Мне было прикольно эксплорить?
Tamaz Gadaev: Эксплорить практики типу а. Сейчас Давайте там в качестве объекта медитации возьмем пространство. Вокруг?
Tamaz Gadaev: А Давайте ощущение как, бы я сжимать и расширять?
Tamaz Gadaev: А Давайте там во такую штуку сделаем. Давайте. Сделаем дуна Семь Или что нибудь еще?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, вообще еще еще, какая, у меня есть практика я. Люблю Смотреть или слушать умные штуки?
Tamaz Gadaev: Тебя. Ядно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Подкаст?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это тоже?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, типа, Это зложный. Способ для меня?
Tamaz Gadaev: И развлечения. Получить И типа. Какой, то. Вайн. Даун Это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Смотреть, какие, то лекции?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что нибудь какие, нибудь там, тоже подкасты, слушать или что, то такое?
Tamaz Gadaev: На сам деле. Это хорошее?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я думаю, что это здесь, хорошая гипотеза?
O!Sapiens Expert: То очень хороший вариант.
Tamaz Gadaev: Это мой главный способ прокрастинировать один из типа, Когда я не?
Tamaz Gadaev: Не хотел готовиться к экзаменам в. Универе я, смотрел, у пеки унные лекции?
Tamaz Gadaev: И потому я сейчас там типа, сколько то, там шарю, в каких, то вещах?
O!Sapiens Expert: Супер?
O!Sapiens Expert: Отлично. Давай найдем что то, что попробуешь.
O!Sapiens Expert: Ближайшее. Время.
Tamaz Gadaev: Со смотрением умных штук есть проблема. Что нужно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Иметь?
Tamaz Gadaev: Под рукой. Список Вещей которые, я могу не думать че выбирать я просто. Открыл сылку поставил все?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Tamaz Gadaev: У меня. Такого списка нет. К. Сожалению?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но тебе, Какие темы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Возможно, нужно завести?
O!Sapiens Expert: Интересных?
Tamaz Gadaev: Философия, Люблю, Много Смотреть про природу сознания?
O!Sapiens Expert: Знаешь, эсэнши, фаундэйшн?
Tamaz Gadaev: Посмотреть?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как?
O!Sapiens Expert: Эсэнчиа Фаундэйшн?
Tamaz Gadaev: Неа?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ютюб спотифай чоте?
Tamaz Gadaev: До чего угодно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Я тебя. Скину. Спатифай?
O!Sapiens Expert: Очень, очень интересный. Подкаст?
O!Sapiens Expert: Крас. Про природо, сознания?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ооо?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот это тема.
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
O!Sapiens Expert: Дескину?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей, Да, Можно, попробовать тогда, с этого начать как Какой. То инструмент?
O!Sapiens Expert: Супер, Давай попробуем это. И здесь. Хочется понять сейчас как, то, резюмирую, именно то, что мы пытались внедрить по части сна. Какие сейчас нам важно взять во внимание аспекты которые бы помогли тебе закрепить тот прогресс, который, уже достигнут?
O!Sapiens Expert: Планешна?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну В, принципи мы, это обсудили что, типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Про воспоминания?
Tamaz Gadaev: Штук?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Есть, можно по сморту. Небольшое сделать типа. Если все пошло по пезде, а то почему?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: То потом?
O!Sapiens Expert: Как сейчас?
O!Sapiens Expert: Здравствуйте, Мне?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Скорее потому, что, у меня возникла?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я думаю, что серия из тусовок и большого количества работы если. Я там три четыре дня, подряд плохо спал?
Tamaz Gadaev: Может не сильно нарушить. Режим.
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Бот. Да, просто?
Tamaz Gadaev: Короче, Мне Кажется просто, держать, осознность в этой сфере регулярно делать эту. Штуку типа вспоминать делать, эту, практику?
Tamaz Gadaev: Про убыток про вспоминания?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вклады в завтрашний день. И всяк такое?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей. Звучит, просто?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это Основная?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну, ну, да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну Да, нам, надо перевести на уровень привычки чтобы, это не было Как, это фрикции чтобы, не надо было каждый раз успоминать, чтобы она уже просто на в пилоте. Поэтому нашей сдача сейчас сделать это минимально простым понятным. И, главное?
O!Sapiens Expert: Создать непространство и подстроить окружающую среду для того чтобытья поддерживала, помогала поэтому ну ту вупы. И Вибрации, Давай, Поробуем здесь тоже начать для того, чтобы понять, как, это работает если, это, не работает поискать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я могу. Я живу с большим количеством людей?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я могу попросить их что нибудь, мне говорить?
Tamaz Gadaev: Напоминать меня, если ты видишь меня там на. Первом, этаже поздно ночью.
Tamaz Gadaev: Можешь мне напомнить сделать, то то, я думаю, что будет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Давай?
Tamaz Gadaev: Много людей, кто быть не против этого?
O!Sapiens Expert: Давай это. Отличный инструмент. Социальная поддержка этажечь. Круто.
Tamaz Gadaev: Помочь. Нет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Если есть люди, которые могут тебе в этом способствовать, то отличная идея?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну Только, приди к ним с чем то, конкретным, из разряда если вы. Видим. Меня здесь там после, не, знаю, полуночи или там. Не важно такого, времени, ты самчитаешь, важным, для этой осечки то говорите мне чтобы. Это я, оставлял. Здесь. Новот. И?
O!Sapiens Expert: Пиздвал?
O!Sapiens Expert: К себе?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Переключаться?
O!Sapiens Expert: Восстанавливаться. Ну. И Обращай внимание на, те, дни когда ты высыпаешься, как ты себя чувствуешь, и пытаешься это где то как тофиксировать или себя тоже рефлексировать. Что вот именно сегодня. Я себя. Не знаю ощущаю, отлично именно. Сегодня там. Я. Еще себе отлично потому, что я там поспала? На количество часов?
O!Sapiens Expert: Как это. Нам Важно ли Нервная система. Закрепить. Новый патерн, и, как, это научить и, закрепить вот эту самую часть которая Такая, типа, окей. Я, Вижу, в. Этом смысл я. Вижу в этом продуктивности вижу что да. Это, действительно приносит пользой ценность и нам, важно. Как это максимально поддержать и культивировать потому, что это, часть идентичности?
O!Sapiens Expert: Из нее собственностроиться. Все дальше. Да, Пока она не сформировалась. Это все еще хрупко и, считается и, как, старые платерные Старые привычки очень легко. Здесь забираются, Поэтому Подумай, как ты можешь себя поддержать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Чтобы ты не создал умножениях путеворовоящей?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Интересно, да, про создание. Идентичности когда. Я?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну чуть Типа, Чуть, чуть, горжусь, с, тобой, что, это делаю там, или думаю да Я, Человек, который, ложится рано, типа. Вообще, Это не там. Строгий. График.
O!Sapiens Expert: Здесь. Я бы перефразировал ито чуть в другую сторону потому что человек который ложится, рано, и, у меня строгий график это больше, как такое, какой то ограничение Такое, вот, я там, вот такой. Да, здесь это скорее про то, что я человек, который приоритезирует самозаботу, и свою личную продуктивность?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что, является как это ценностью на уровень выше но, Из нее следует то что ты оберегаешь, свой сон как что то, что является просто необсуждаемой базой и ключевым приоритетом для. Тебя?
Tamaz Gadaev: Гм?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но, очевидно, мой приоритет. Сейчас. Это Стартап, и типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я тогда для меня добыт. Формулироваться, так, что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я, человек, который умеет инженерить свой образ жизни под задачу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, очень важную задачу И части этого инженеринга в, том, чтобы спать нормальным?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, Ну, и придерживаться да. Что, можно инженерить но?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мне реализовать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. Да, да, да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей, Супер, Хорошо тогда. Смотри. Если, Говорим, про дальше, как намерение, продолжать или, нет?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, Да Давай продолжать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Хорошо, Тогда. Ну, Эти, сылку направлю. Также на оплату следующего месяца и мы, Здесь Плавно будем переходить к. Тому. Чтобы ну, Во, Первых, все дальше больше закреплять сон но будем уже обращать внимание на питание потому что это является, дейстно очень важным аспектом это все взаимозависимо. То, как ты ешь что, ты, ешь?
Tamaz Gadaev: Блин?
Tamaz Gadaev: Можем?
O!Sapiens Expert: Бледное, Сон?
Tamaz Gadaev: Можем лучше про спорт, то, что питание самое сложное я гарантирую, Там будет.
Tamaz Gadaev: Духо я, всего ссыпаться спорт будет проще. Я думаю?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы можем пойти в Спорт. Здесь есть важный момент что, питание, сказывается в том, числе, на том, как, ты, воспринимаешь спорт. На Том как, у, тебя организм работает метаболизм, и так далее?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да?
Tamaz Gadaev: С питание у. Меня вот момент что, типа я сильно завищу то. Есть?
Tamaz Gadaev: Просто. Люди заказывают дело доставки?
Tamaz Gadaev: Перейти на свойствие к питания?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я сейчас вообще не вижу возможным. Типа. Никак.
O!Sapiens Expert: Не, Нет, Смотри тут. Это. Минимальные простые решения этого словно говоря создать какой нибудь кастемный агент там, в, комнате же пяти. Или неважно, где и когда. У тебя, коллеги, твои заказывают, едут, им, просто кидаешь меню и, говоришь?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что для меня сейчас самое подходящее с этого меню все.
Tamaz Gadaev: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Очень, просто?
Tamaz Gadaev: Понял, понял?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну, смотри, Если, хочешь, в движение давай в движение просто По логике Питание у, тебя, влияет на все. На Сон на движение в, том, числе?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, просто движения это. Более лоухэнни Фрут что Мы на, питании могут? Зависнуть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Файн файн файн Хорошо, Давай Тогда. Обращать. Внимание, На, движение. Как сейчас введи лог самочувствие когда, ты, Что делаешь. В течение дня. Как это сказывается на качестве твоего сна и, что, получается легче всего?
O!Sapiens Expert: Где, какие сложности и, это мы как, раз будем разбирать наши. Следующий. Встречи?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ага?
Tamaz Gadaev: Все по севоте.